hello guys Ryan the right here I'm Katy
dubov Katherine du Bois
Kate Kate Katie yeah because we're
friends Katie because you know yeah yeah
it's a personal vibe on this channel
rakho rakha she hasn't seen any iraq
iraq of videos these guys what I noticed
is the most common thing is they do
these sketches that end up going down a
really dark violent path like faces
though cuz you know I don't like faces
being disseminated like we should put it
like this thing they did a sketch called
real-life Mortal Kombat fatalities oh I
don't know if this one's gonna be
violent or not but let's find out okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh Jesus Wow it they get funnier because
you start getting that what makes it so
funny is how violent it is dude I
thought it was awesome that was I
thought it was visceral and super fun
the other one likes people who really
know how to do stunts do videos cuz
those guys were pros
you could tell at least one of them was
for sure the other guys I met like two
of them I met and they kind of just sort
of film buffs I'm really into like
dramas yeah they know how to stage a
fight no yeah they literally got a
budget with their projects now all the
thrashing they do and the violence the
makeup effects and they always shoot
them like handheld and I wanna like like
just yeah get in there I want it to
happen to my balls
all right so um Rago ragga yeah I mean
don't you get that vibe that these are
guys who are like coming up with these
skits kind of like just hanging out of
their home in the sense of that nama
saying they're not prepared but I feel
like their ideas kind of go down that
way like what if these people got so
into Assassin's Creed and then took it
way too far how much they got I didn't
do it
I loved seeing a sketch like that like a
great what if this happened kind of
sketch some of them how Hollywood's best
movies are made is it
you had the what-if theory all right
name name some successful movies The
Godfather what if we did a movie about
the Italian I don't know never mind
Katie you know the great what if theory
actually came from Russia from the
stanislavski's system who is the
godfather of method acting he was the
first person to introduce what if into
the culture before that it was all like
weird gestures on the stage but after
what if people actually started saying
okay like let's make movies let's make
theater like real life instead of like
puppetry the more you know what I look
crap load of crap that's not what you
bring me on this show
no no should I like more cleavage is
what's necessary Wow combination of that
ripping my balls off yeah that was great
full-contact one day we'll actually
review the video they were watching I
wasn't really sure what the girl was
doing the islands like I wish that we
had least saw her my stander in the
beginning so that her reveal as the King
character was a surprise instead she
just seemed completely random
isn't she a character from the game yeah
she is but all the other people you got
to see them before they transfer their
characters she just came in the last leg
10 seconds of the film okay weird she
even come from she wasn't like it was
you yeah writing standpoint yeah rekka
record you need to write a little better
this is a funny idea of like who's
better
yeah and then he was better they were
giving him all this [ __ ] in the
beginning but he survived Rocco Rocco
brother Craigslist's - I know trust me
there are some worse sketches I can show
you so anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you're new to it you
can subscribe today by clicking this
button above my head become a reject a
bot today catherine du Bois follow her
on her facebook Katy operate on
Instagram mm-hmm
what's your Twitter you never find you
Katie du Bois mm-hmm I think we're
friends though Mike Santos Philly oh hey
yeah Philly oh yeah hey guys you guys
are awesome making highly entertaining
videos and segments might be hard but
you guys pull that off real parentheses
are AEL real real Wow keep making more
movie reviews because that's the most
informative and accurate reviews I've
ever watched feel like I've let you down
I don't really do this as often as I'd
like to top of my list is the hot girls
getting on board with Brian every
reaction video Oh girls damn Ryan are
you a wizard or some [ __ ] no oh no no I
normally go along with the bit but I'm
gonna say today no I'm not thanks guys
make us always entertain with your crazy
ass jokes and hilarious punchlines
you guys are awesome Mike Santos Folio
listen if you want to know how to get
girls it's this simple hey I have a
youtube channel I'm really trying to get
at places you'll want to guess start and
that's how Ryan met Katie met
and every other female I know and then
somehow you just convinced them to do
YouTube and then you just keep doing
more YouTube videos oh yeah not a
beautiful friendship purchase
think I'm gonna play yes and with you on
that come on yes and anyway Mike saying
yes that's how you get a girl